[Music]
[Laughter]
right everyone starting to come
in
welcome
welcome oops that was
me I cannot open
[Music]
into while we're getting settled in here
let us know where you're from in the
chat see where everyone's checking in in
from we've got
Mexico hello
[Music]
hello Michigan the lamb that's a
hand that's all I'll ever say when I
hear
Michigan Canada and Texas Romania York
South Africa we got everyone
here London Los
Angeles gang's all here yes New Jersey
that's where I'm from he Town South
Africa
your you guys we're going to get started
in just a few minutes here we just want
to give everyone a chance to come on in
and then we will start talking all
things
[Applause]
marketing hey green South Carolina not
far from
[Music]
you
Michael I'm down or was down south
Jersey so like 30 minutes out of Philly
in
Sal yes this will be I believe we're
keeping them on YouTube right Carrie yep
okay we are but just know the special
stuff going on is only gonna be while
we're live so just keep that in in mind
for
yourself I'm in Philly my favorite
City people always tease me for that but
it is so we're just going to put it out
[Music]
there
all right we got just about a minute
here we're going to go ahead and Jump On
In
[Music]
I can't listen to music and not move you
have no idea how hard it is for me to
like stay calm and wait I'm dancing y
all you just can't see me I was fully
prepared to come on video and it just
did not want to happen today so we're
we're rolling with it camera is just
having a good old time not cooperating
it's how it goes sometimes in business
right yeah you just never know you never
know what's gonna go Ben and Chris if
you're watching I was fully gonna go
live it it I'm I have the camera set up
so
yep all right you guys what do you say
we go ahead and get started Charles
thank you so much everything sounds good
on mics Carrie I hear you good I think
we are ready to get to it all right so
we are all here for one reason and one
reason only marketing your creative
business um second is because you may
have heard there's something extra
special that's going to be happening
today and we'll talk about that in just
a bit so number one our agenda for today
is we're going to do some introductions
so you know who these two women over
here on the leftand side I believe of
your screen is we're going to do some
brain storing live for some marketing
ideas for your creative business mostly
to help you get out of your own head
right for you to be able to see other
ways that you can be showing up that
feel good for you um also choosing your
focus because I don't know about you but
once I brainstorm and I have this huge
list of things it then becomes a well
where do I start with this right because
like now it's a lot of things and we
don't want to leave you with that so
we're going to going to choose your
focus and then we're going to talk about
creating your plan so what plan do you
need to go into the new year with for
yourself we want to make sure that
you're walking away from here with
actionable steps that you can take to
Market your business we're also going to
make sure that you get exclusive access
to our flash sale now I don't know if
you heard what happened last week when
Ben and Stephanie were on live they
dropped a flash sale and you had seven
minutes to take advantage of it and it
was
incredible it was going bananas over
here on our end we saw the chat firing
away and we're gonna do something
similar today here on this live stream
so you get to learn you also get to see
so we're going to tell you all about
that as we get closer The Flash sale was
dope yes well welcome back Charles I'm
excited to have you guys back here
because we're going to learn a whole
different topic but still have a lot of
The Flash sales goodies so a little bit
about us Carrie why don't you go ahead
and kick us off here yeah sounds great
hi y'all my name is Carrie green and I
am the marketing director here at the
future I started my journey in marketing
and business in my early 20s and I'm
going to date myself here close to 25
years ago um with a brick and mortar
store from there I shifted gears and was
a tech advisor for an IP law firm in
that role um I helped companies kind of
identify their unique aspects of their
technology to help them get the patents
um where does that fit into online
marketing um this experience really
helped me figure out what makes
businesses stand out the ones that are
being successful and thriving
um since then I have had the privilege
of guiding hundreds of entrepreneurs to
create and improve their marketing and
sales funnels um I'm really passionate
about leveraging Innovative marketing to
transform your business and the lives
for the better so I'm really looking
forward to sharing some insights with
you guys today um Jess what about you
yes so my name is Jessica Rodriguez I am
the marketing manager here at the future
I also create and support online
businesses that aim to leave the world a
better place than they found it I have
spent the past decade supporting some
incredible clients in both the B2B and B
Toc spaces I have been on some top name
podcasts on stages and really my biggest
claim to fame is just being able to live
a life that allows me to live my
definition of freedom driven success
each and every day and while that sounds
like one great little elevator pitch
there why I'm actually here is because
before I got into the online space back
in 2012 I was a senior graphic designer
at an agency with over $71,000 of debt
on my shoulders and pretty much pay most
of my paycheck towards that debt and the
reason why is because I didn't know
there was any other way to learn the
skills that I needed than the
traditional path of Education I thought
that you had to spend that kind of money
and just hope you make it back one day
not realizing that learning a new skill
doesn't need to cost an arm and both
legs and that definitely felt like what
I was paying in my 20s which is what
brought me here to the Future and what
really excites me because when you look
at our courses our toolkits our
resources there is a wealth of knowledge
available at affordable prices right at
prices that you can actually make your
money back from um ones that don't
consist of taking out fullon loans or
anything like that to need to get what
you need to go to that next level but
this month specifically is extra special
because for the month of November we've
been giving 25% off everything in the
catalog so every course every toolkit
the merch all of that you can get for
25% off all month long which I look at
that and I'm like oh my God like I want
to buy things even though I'm here
already at the future just because it's
an amazing sale to be able to be a part
of and if you haven't taken a look yet
Carrie actually can you pop that in the
chat um we created a lookbook earlier
this month and these are the pages
you're seeing from there and in that
lookbook not only has all of the courses
but curriculums that you can take a look
at and really see what are the things I
need to learn what does that look like
whether it is from the future or from
friends of the future which are other
businesses and people who are teaching
you can take a look at all of that in
one place so with
that our one and only mission is to help
you make a living doing what you love
and in order for us to be able to do
that we bring in some of the best of the
best authors to help with these products
and courses and everything that's put
out we put out free content like this on
this YouTube channel and also the future
main Channel there is a wealth of
knowledge available so that you can
really have what it is that you want
which now brings us to marketing right
because the reality is I could say all
this stuff
but you can't do the work you love and
get paid well for it if no one knows
your business exists right there is just
no way for people to know that your work
is of value if they don't know you're
out there if they don't know that you
have these skill sets and for me that's
all marketing is it's letting somebody
know that you and or your business
exists so they can then take that next
step so as we get started here I'd love
to just do a check-in and see how do you
feel about Marketing in your business
there is no right or wrong answer here I
just want to see in the chat kind of
where people are at coming in for
this oh I see some courses people are
grabbing that's awesome I know I know
Charles and
Diego so as we were looking um not good
okay as as we look at Market Research in
our inbox if you're writing the
marketing you're hitting one of us we
see a lot of these feelings right we see
a lot of exhaustion we feel or see a lot
of people feeling lost because there's
so many different ways you can Market
your business which you think would be a
good thing but it also can be a very
confusing thing for people like which
one do I do I see this person doing
really well with this strategy and I see
this person and doing really well with
the other one I don't know which one to
take and I feel like a lot of us have
very limited time so you're not trying
to take on everything right maybe you're
feeling overwhelmed you finally get one
thing going for you and then it stops
and apparently now you have to do five
times the work to get the same Onex
return and that's overwhelming you're
annoyed you're tired you're just feeling
me we just came out of and I mean we
could still say we're in it um some of
the hardest years
and guess what marketing may not be the
number one thing that lights you up out
of everything let's see um I work in a
marketing department currently but mine
is
crazy see find the time Paul I mean I
think we all feel like that we you know
we're good at it but our stuff it's hard
to do it for yourself I I get that one
Paul yes absolutely um there's a meme I
always go back to and it's uh Patrick
from SpongeBob and it's like solving
everyone else's problems and you're
really excited and you have all the
answers right and you're super smart and
then it's trying to solve my own and
he's just like hammering a piece of into
his own
head you know and it's like oh I'm so
much better at solving everyone else's
stuff but then when it comes to me it's
like what do I do who am I right um so
LoveHate relationship a sticky one
frustrated okay need it now
hate
it all right just taking a look and
seeing and I hope you guys are reading
the chat too because I think there's
always so much value in business of just
being able to see oh I'm not alone right
because if you look online it may seem
like everybody's just crushing it and
everyone loves their life and everyone's
doing great and it's not that you want
to focus on the negative necessarily but
you just want to be like oh okay we're
all figuring this out okay we're all
finding our way just at different levels
and different stages and I just I always
think there's power so thank you for
everyone sharing in the chat
here so now let's flip it okay how do
you want to feel about marketing your
business because you're not going to get
away from it if you want your business
to get known you're gonna need to Market
it right um and we're GNA talk about the
how of that in just a bit but I'm just
curious have you ever thought about what
it would feel like on the other side of
everything you just wrote so do you want
it to be exciting confident and clear oh
those are good words like to know that
you are showing up and hey this is the
thing I'm doing and I'm following
through with it I feel clear on it I
feel good about it it's the right
strategy for me um and I can lead with
that want it to be automated confident
okay simplified simp I love that word
I don't think anyone can see it here I'm
like it's actually right behind me um uh
I don't want to be a slimy salesperson
Charles you know the thing I love about
that why marketing I'm gonna hit the
next slide because this is actually what
I'm about to go
into um marketing for me my goal is for
it to be fun and it's because I always
see it as an extension of myself an
extension of my own audience an
extension of what it is that I have to
share with the world world and when I
approach it from that way then any kind
of strategy or idea I pull is going to
have that route of fun enjoyment service
those type of things that mean something
to me and I find that a lot of times
yeah like there's plenty of marketing
strategies that I see online and I'm
like if that's what it takes I don't
want it I'm just I'm not open to it and
I'm like you know what but that works
for that person I'm assuming right like
if that works for that person that is
great so always trying to remember that
of hey if that's an extension of someone
they are a sleazy slimy person and
that's the extension of their
marketing okay what's the extension for
me right like what is that look like and
that's why I wanted to ask you guys this
question too because I think a lot of
people uh have that misconception that
marketing can feel like very icky and
it's because you've seen it in ways that
didn't match up with you and that's Fair
now you just know what not to do right
um so we want to help you really allow
marketing to be fun so if you guys are
down for that let's do some exploration
here um this is why I love a creative
audience because you just already have
the mindset of being creative we just
got to move it over here right like just
to a different area
so number one is just asking yourself
because here's the secret to everything
I'll tell you this you always know the
answer okay um so let's first check in
with yourself what are all the ways that
you could let people know that your
business exists before I tell you some
ways I want you to come up with your own
first and just pop them in the chat
remember no wrong answers here we're
just all hanging out okay um let me see
it's hard to not sound like a copy paste
in tone and content either oh yeah we
definitely don't want that right like
you want to you have your own mannerisms
you have your own way of talking that
can go into it so what are all the ways
that you could let people know that it
exists um share what I do with them
social media obvious social of course
right like that's that's our default now
because we're we're so used to being in
a social world uh LinkedIn showing it be
present share what I do awesome okay so
let's go back so as you're thinking of
this
I want you to remember this the best way
that you can come up with fresh ideas is
to forget everything you've already done
okay nothing has worked nothing has
failed if you're in business for a long
time if you've had some things that work
sometimes it can work against you
because all you're thinking about is
back in this day right if I talked about
10 years ago posted on Facebook
everybody saw my stuff now I don't even
touch the platform right so I can't
romanticize old stuff and then this same
thing if something
failed you can't take that with you oh
we can never do that idea again because
it failed no you probably just have to
change it if you enjoyed it you probably
have to change it so when you're in this
brainstorming phase I want you to
remember nothing has happened okay like
you have to keep reminding yourself not
to say but what about or stop or this um
Carry do you
remember I feel like it was 10 years ago
but it was pretty much like a month ago
right
yeah when we were brainstorming this
sale
yeah what were some of the ideas that we
threw out there and see the rule was
none of us were allowed to say no you
just had to put like Ben Burns had a
paper up or a dock or whatever up and we
just had to spout things off nobody was
allowed to shut it down do you remember
some of the things we had yeah it was
just when he said that too it was like
that pressure of having to get it right
in that moment it just completely went
away um so yeah some of the things we
came up with was nothing we would do
absolutely
nothing and um just make a big deal
about it right we'll just do nothing for
H Black Friday um a digital escape room
uh where we solve puzzles and unlock
deals um
get roasted by Chris because you know
why not so on a live stream um we
thought about doing a QBC style type
live stream getting really cheesy with
it um and then we also um had had on
there like an all night Marathon you
know streaming you know 24 hours a day
all night kind of Sleepover type thing
so I mean there was many many more but
um it was very it was a very fun
exercise to do yes and that's actually
where the lookbook came from so if you
downloaded the lookbook it was one of
the many things that was on that list um
the the flash sale that we're about to
do part of that was a conversation about
the Nike app and they do drops of shoes
right like there was just so much on
that list and remember the goal was not
to say oh that could be a tech nightmare
or that could be a customer support
nightmare
or I remember even with the marathon
idea my mind went I don't think they
realize there's two things I love going
to bed early and sleeping for a long
time I do not hang all night like I
would never survive doesn't matter
that's not the point right we're not
thinking of those things we're just
getting everything out onto the table
and then you can strategize right then
you can poke holes and you can do all
that but you have to give yourself space
right um so I want you to really think
of this heavy on the early bedtime
yes and we got a new mattress last year
so like forget it you're done it's over
yeah it's absolutely over so let's talk
about some ways with your own business
so we did have somebody say uh post on
social media sure social's available
right like it's free debatably right um
to be able to post ask your clients to
share SL referrals so sometimes you just
have to ask for what you want some
people are very natural with referrals
other people aren't so you could reach
out and say hey I really loved working
with you um I would love to work with
more people like you they probably know
them right you're probably already
friends with them um sending your
portfolio out to 50 people why 50 just
picked a number didn't matter right
we're not overthinking it um direct
Outreach so whether that's via email
it's on the phone like how are you
reaching out to people you could start a
blog or a podcast you could and remember
anything goes so look around you could
hire a pilot to fly a banner with your
website on it we have them at the beach
by us all the time and they just like
here want to drink this water while
you're at the beach smart right um you
could pull those ideas from other
people this one I remember Carrie saying
this one as we were brainstorming
pulling from other Industries right
so your face on a bus like your face on
a bench your face on a popsicle like I
don't know it doesn't matter like you
just there's so many different ideas
could you imagine if like I even thought
of this like if I was going down the
street and I saw a bus that was like H
hire me to illustrate your book I'm like
yeah I don't even have a book but now
I'm curious
go look at their stuff because I've
never seen someone do it right like
these are just ways to be able to put
yourself out there um case studies you
could tag your clients of course if you
have approval to be able to do that
tagging your clients you could go stand
on the corner this would be really weird
for me because I'm almost on a dead end
Street and nobody's there but I could go
stand with a sign that has my website on
it like Curious go ahead and do
it so I would definitely take a photo
had the vision of the the little man at
the car uh dealerships or whatever with
the little Sketti noodle a you know that
was
it see and that's the thing like you pay
attention and you remember but at one
time somebody said let's put this
ridiculous inflatable up and everyone
was like why now it's a thing right it's
a thing so yeah um creating Flyers
business cards I'm sure you guys have
them too where you know different uh
local shops things like that uh they
have the boards up that you can put your
your business cards and things like that
up local networking events
conferences this is a book I just added
to this slide I read it over this summer
um and I love it I love the concept of
it it's get different from Mike mallwitz
you can get it on Amazon you can get it
on all the things and he goes through
like different ways to think about
marketing and he does like a ton of case
studies within the book too of just like
talking about different ways that people
put ads out there you know all that good
stuff with marketing and what happened
and also how to tell when something
works and doesn't work and all of that I
just I think it's a great book on this
topic so I felt weird not to include it
while we're I haven't read that one yet
I'm gonna have to go grab it yeah it's
really good I I'm a Mike mallwitz fan
girl so like I like a lot of his books
but um this one's really good and he has
a good humor as well like it's a a fun
read and you could also you know oh
apparently I hired a pilot twice I was
very excited about that
idea I now have the money to do it twice
um podcast ad you can collaborate with
other businesses that you know are
also uh working with your people just in
a different way right so there's a lot
of different ways when you are allowing
yourself to get creative uh Charles I
read the pumpkin plan and profit first
yes I think profit it's probably right
there if my bookshelves uh show that's
one of my like you must read that book
in
business so the goal here with this
whole exercise and I hope this is one
that you pull in all different areas of
your business because it allows us to
just get back to let's just play Let's
just have fun let's remember what it's
like to just have ideas before our adult
self starts to come in and go
like let's just
let's put ideas out there get out of
your own head because when you see
different campaigns or people doing
things differently it's because at one
point they just had this random idea and
decided to try it instead of saying all
the reasons it wouldn't work right and
there's so many things out there that
people do try that don't work and that's
just part of the game right like you
could post something we see it on the
future account like I could get real
excited about a post going up and I'm
like Maybe not maybe I just like that um
and then something else that I just do
on a whim and you guys are loving it and
it's like uh okay like you just never
know and that's part of marketing is
like not taking it so seriously yes you
can have a strategy and yes you can be
aware of those things but at the front
end how are you allowing yourself to
just have fun with it and enjoy and see
it as this extension right of
yourself so let's take a look at some
examples okay so how are ways that we
can kind of think of marketing outside
of just here's what we know and here's
what we normally do so number one I was
just looking online and I found this
article I do not know Ben O'Brien but I
love this book that he has created so
essentially what he did is he said you
know I have these pieces I have a social
media account and I was reading a
website where it was a bunch of
creatives talking about social media and
how they're kind of starting to get away
from it as much just you know for a lot
of different reasons as far as
algorithms or just wanting to feel
creative again and there's just there's
a weird um thing going on right as far
as like algorithms and the creatives and
what as I was reading that article this
came up where if you go to his Instagram
you can play this real and it's
something that goes out to Art Direct
people that would be hiring him and it's
just the best of his illustrations like
what he wants people to see and for some
people they be like oh like people do
that how often how often do people do
print things anymore right doesn't that
stand out when you now have an industry
that has moved so far digitally and like
oh if people want to see my stuff they
can go see it on my website they can and
he still has a website up and he still
has work there right like that's still a
very valid thing but also hey I can mail
this to you in the mail if you're
interested in my work you can physically
have it in your hands
and I think kri I'm curious if you're
like this too um I don't throw away
handmade stuff like I can't I physically
cannot don't either yeah or anything
that's art type of thing like anything
my mind classifi in that category I
cannot like I would feel so bad which
means he's going to be front of mind
because I'm always going to keep it
right yeah so it's just being able to
kind of think about these things so we
all love Nostalgia too so there's
something to be said about that and like
all the meme accounts and all you know
like those kind of things that we look
at so what was something that was the
norm in your industry that people have
gotten away from and is there an
opportunity for you to use it to your
advantage because now it stands you out
right before I came to the future I used
to like after so many sales I would
start pulling a couple names and write
handwritten cards on purpose and I'm
like why because nobody does that so
then you mail it and it gives a whole
different feeling right for the person
even if they didn't spend a lot so know
that you know anything I'm sharing it
doesn't have to cost a lot of money for
you to do it it's more of the thought
process behind it of hey what's
something that just isn't done in my
industry anymore but used to be done
before X right before all the
things another thing we're going to
share is the brand lab boxes so I these
are so
beautiful I love this
box way
more so if you guys have heard um Chris
launched a mastermind called brand lab
and this is the first cohort that just
started in October so they're going
through and working with Chris and
getting their personal brand up and all
of that so as we were preparing for it
it was like you know what for these
people what if we make a custom box a
brand lab welcome box that they can open
and just feel special right like how
much do we all love getting happy things
in the mail right like you get in there
you're like oh my God it's not a bill
right so so why don't we give them this
experience with this box now we could
have just made a box put the things in
it and shipped it and it would have been
great but isn't there another
opportunity here how many people are
going to see that box between the time
it leaves the offices in California to
wherever it's going because it's
worldwide right as far as people that we
support you know
there could be potential for people who
would be interested in brand lab so I
know this is a little small on the slide
so I'm going to talk it through the
promise of brand lab is here
intentionally because if you read it
it's not it's not catchy it's clear for
a reason here's exactly what brand lab
is for and who it's for because if
someone read that and they went oh I
want to create a personal brand like
that's what I've been looking for well
then great because the URL for the sales
page is right here and if you happen to
miss that while you're stalking somebody
else's box down you can hit the URL
right here which is the Future Okay and
then the cards inside also ask if they
want to share to share on Instagram and
how to tag Chris in the future um
because if they share then of course
their people go oh what's that that you
joined brand lab it's amazing right so
this is something where you start to
think think the the answer is not okay I
need to make a a custom box for my
people how much is this going to cost me
no it's a thought process behind it so
what or where are there opportunities to
maximize what's already in front of
people so is there anything that you're
sending out and if so what could you do
to up that a little bit to just see
other or have other people see your
business
okay and then this was a fun one that
came up and again it doesn't have to be
very expensive to Market in some
different ways and I'm not saying this
is the end all be all way this is just
one of many ways that you can explore so
fast food and Spotify like who would
have thought that McDonald's is rocking
a Spotify list not I right but here's
the thing they're they're marketing
everywhere right they're on billboards
all the things that they have going on
if you're just scrolling through Spotify
and you're typing in random things and
you put Mick anything because you're
trying to find you know a certain artist
or a podcast and that pops
up you know what that does for your mind
if you like McDonald's if you're driving
by in the car and you see when you're
like oh I was in the mood right like oh
it kind of just plants that seat in
there and that's that's different levels
of marketing but see how they're still
getting in front of people like oh our
people are on
Spotify okay what am I supposed to do
about that you could make a playlist
right like there's so many ways I've
been to a lot of business events that
they did uh playlists for their event so
it was like different songs that were at
the event and then they would have ones
to like hype you up before you did the
event you know different things like
that and it's just getting creative with
what's out there and what's available
and also sometimes just what's free that
you could uh use for
yourself and then another one that is
usually untapped is Brands um brand
using gifs gifs whatever you call it I
say gifs so I'm going to keep going with
that is a great example of what do you
naturally use or do that markets
somebody else's brand but you could be
using it for your own so at first when
I'm looking I see Gary ve okay of of
course he has these like I'd be
surprised if he didn't so he has these
he's a a front-facing right a personal
brand okay what if I don't want to be a
personal brand du
lingo they're one of my favorite Brands
out there okay well they took their icon
and just made it a thing right like they
turned their whole brand into this bird
right um if we go over here this is Bick
and really nothing spectacular would
stand out for me as far as like oh I
could pull that until I start looking
and I go oh some of these which this may
be a probably too small to see is
they'll have the image and then they
have their logo at the bottom of it so
if you're sharing you know set of pens
type of thing because you just want to
have like a fun thing on your stories
their logos underneath it so I'm seeing
Bick as I'm going through people's
stories right um because of how they did
that so I'm like o that's an interesting
take so if I have a personal brand yeah
I can make one of myself but if I didn't
maybe there's a way that my logo or
certain an icon or something within my
brand I could bring more to the
Forefront and have my name or something
underneath it right so that it kind of
does that work for me and it's out there
right like it's out there for free so
again this may not be your way but see
how it just starts to generate some
different ideas of oh what would be a
fun way to do it right like what would
be an interesting way for me to do it
which is a heck of a lot better than
doing nothing right um and just allowing
yourself to think outside the box for
yourself so now of everything that we
talked about in the chat I would love to
hear what are three marketing efforts
that excite you to try even if it's like
this little spark of like I can do that
that's okay we take all wins a win is a
win right so I want you to be able to
start seeing what it is for you right
like what are those things for you that
get you really um excited Duo watches me
in my sleep oh Spencer I had to shut off
the
notifications I thought I wanted to
learn
Spanish I don't think I wanted to learn
that
much I was being stalked purely stalked
by
Duo let's see um custom gifts would be a
really cool idea to create yeah I'm
surprised like how many people have them
that like I don't even like I'm like oh
yeah it's so easy to do we just don't
think of it right because we're we're
doing all these other
things um what platform can you share
gifts so the ones I showed you those are
all Instagram and I know if you put um
like gift for business or gift stickers
for business I think it was and Google
it'll talk you through how to create
that because I I was way down in a
rabbit hole once I started exploring
that uh Duo is borderline
abusive I love their accounts Spotify
list uh let's see insta and giy are cool
yes definitely and explore those like
see what's going out um just do
something done is better than perfect oh
yes please
like I mean Carrie can probably vouch
for how many things have gone out for me
with like a spelling mistake or
something um yep I mean same with me too
that's
like I do it too links dates you know
just um all kind of stuff that's but
it's better to get it out than not doing
it at all exactly and like humans
everyone is human which means we all
have faults and we all have things that
aren't going to necessarily go our way
um but that's the thing like we want to
be able to just try things right like
have fun you're supposed to enjoy what
you're doing what's the point of
building your own business if you're not
having fun doing it right so you get to
create but let's also bring that same
creativity into your marketing right um
so as you're looking at these things I
want you to ask yourself like what do
you need to learn in order to make those
marketing efforts the most effective for
you now whenever I'm asking these
questions for myself it's always from a
place of awareness versus judgment okay
yes so this is never that excuse to be
like here's all the things I don't know
and then I make a list and I'm like sad
me right like look I don't know things
um because you can learn anything like
the internet is a beautiful beautiful
place um so you get to give yourself
that opportunity but you have to be real
with yourself right like okay if I want
to start attracting people on social
media and like that's what I want to
lean
into but if I'm being honest my
messaging is not good all right like
I've had people look at my stuff and
they go I don't know what you actually
do I'm like
oh okay so let me be honest if I do want
to lead with social this could also go
for direct Outreach like this can go for
a lot of things and my messaging is off
let me write that down right because I
want to address that I want to fix it um
if let's say you are doing some Outreach
which Outreach is such a powerful
powerful tool if you're doing that
Outreach but you have a really not great
for lack of a better words portfolio and
you're not being mean to yourself you're
just being honest my portfolio is not
that great or I am pretty much like
throwing everything and the kitchen sink
at them so when somebody looks at my
portfolio they're like what do they do
like I don't even understand this oh I
should probably go pair down my
portfolio right like I should grab a
rock your portfolio or I should be an
accelerator like I should get certain
levels of support
that can help me have a strong portfolio
so I can do that Outreach and it's more
effective for me or a lot of times I'll
see where people want all the leads in
and you want all the clients and I get
it because right that's part of why
we're in business but the problem is you
don't know how to handle them right so
there's no legal in place there's no
processes there's no onboarding there's
none of that so
I know I've had this feeling so I'll
just admit it where you get really
excited because somebody pays and you're
like yes we can start I'm rich oh and
then immediately crush your yes I've
done that so many times it's not even
funny you see the notification come in
and you're like oh my problems are
solved and then you're like oh my God so
you start running to your email to like
craft the whole like thing because
there's no process right um and if you
guys want to let's be honest in the
comments if you're like just put me if
you've been that person where it's like
I forgot this part right I didn't
systemize this part so then it's hard
for me to Market if I know I can't
handle the people coming in from it
right like oh if I'm gonna put myself
out there more or I'm G to amplify my
current efforts I actually can't handle
the increase of people because I'm
barely hanging on with like what I have
right now um this is your time to be
honest with yourself because all of this
goes together right like nothing in
business really works in a silo they all
Impact each other so that's why I like
to have this literally have this
conversation with myself right like okay
like what's gonna allow it to be
effective and what can I do about that
and how can I be honest with hey there's
some things like some bridges that need
to happen here and sometimes Jess I
think too it's
um confidence a mindset like
copywriting I told myself for years that
I just don't know how to write you know
taking a couple copywriting
courses acted as more of validation that
I'm I'm I don't suck as bad as I think I
do you know and then picking up some
tips here and there but a boost of
confidence too um learning and kind of
digging into things as well
yeah absolutely and this gives you that
opportunity especially because we're
going into a new year right of like oh
what do I need to learn because if
you're here right now we already know
you have passion covered nobody comes to
a YouTube live if you're not passionate
about this right um so we have the
passion then you look at your creative
skill set okay what what needs to be
improved right like what are things that
I can do and even as we were prepping
for this the season of saving sale I was
looking through like a lot of the
courses and such for the future just to
write you know content and promo stuff
for it now I have a design background so
like I should have learned a lot of this
stuff you would think um in school and
I'm clicking through like I think I told
Carrie I was going through the
illustration course and I was
like I could have used
this is
great this is so great yeah and I just
didn't know like I didn't know the gaps
that I had in my skill set I didn't know
where else to go I thought like oh do I
have to just go for a master's now like
is that how I'm going to learn more
things in order to elevate my career and
I don't want to do it I don't want to go
back to school so I thought that was the
only way so this is how we start to
figure that out um and then also your
business skill set so you could have all
the creative skills in the
world and you could be amazing at what
you do but if you don't know how to do
the business components then you're
struggling right because you're like oh
I do great work for the people that come
to me but I don't have enough people and
I'm still struggling and I'm not being
like my financial needs are not being
met you're underpriced like all of those
things that start to happen this is
where we start to bring the business in
it as well and say Hey you can be just
as creative over and business as well
when you're thinking about it
differently right so this is why we have
like in the shop your proposals like how
do you actually create a proposal that
clients say yes to or potential clients
say yes to how do you set up your
operations right like Carrie and I were
going through the opsis course to learn
notion right to use it for the future um
and that's because guess what like that
was something that we needed to bridge
that gap for ourselves we said well we
got course for that might as well like
go through that so this is where you
start to check in and see what's
happening right for yourself and what it
is that you need in order to hit all
three of these areas okay and this is
also when you create your plan so
remember I said there's no judgment in
this plan this is just a list it's for
you um it's for you to be able to have
so that you can be honest with yourself
and say what creative skill sets do I
need to improve and if you need a little
help on that in the lookbook and you'll
see it right here um curriculums are
there for you to show you the skills for
a graphic designer for a lettering
artist for a photographer Carrie name
some more I'm like don't let me forget
web designer graphic design um
videography I'm probably saying stuff
you already said lettering um yeah all
trust us and I'm dropping the a lookbook
link in the chat again it's a long link
so yall just GNA have to copy and paste
it but here it
comes awesome and
then perfect thank you so we have our
creative skill sets and then on the
other side is going to be your business
skill set so what are the things that
you need some people are going to be
heavier on needing some creative skill
sets maybe you're newer maybe you're
changing what it is that you want to be
offering to the world and you're like oh
I need to bridge some of these skills
right like or um Bridge some of these
gaps or you're on the business side and
you're like look I feel like my creative
skills I could get better there's always
room to grow but I really need some
business help right like there's a lot
of things that I just really need
someone who understands what it's like
to be a creative to help me through that
you're going to list those things out
and I want you to check in as you're
doing this to see will these things help
my marketing become easier or maybe more
efficient is this going to help with
that marketing idea I had and that's why
I like to pair it down to three so you
can kind of do this as a litmus test for
yourself and just check in and say hey
is everything going together if it's not
now you know what to change the thing I
love that we're doing this at the end of
this year too is because as you go into
next year everyone's going to get a
little quiet over the next month right
everyone's gonna kind of like be doing
their thing and then January is Gonna
Come and all you're gonna see is like
make a million dollars doing this make a
jillion dollars doing this create one
piece of work and everything will be
solved right like you're GNA see all of
that and it's fine right like it's
everybody's like different ways of
marketing but you look at that and you
find the thing that you're like H Mimi
right find that thing and then come back
to your plan and go does it hit any of
these categories if it does then you can
plan to work on that right like okay I'm
gonna Master this thing okay I'm gonna
take this thing if it doesn't you say I
love that Journey for you and you scroll
on by bless it and go on yeah yes so
this is where you really start to really
just keep your eyes on your own paper to
be honest right like this is where you
start to narrow in your focus and be
honest what is it that I need let me get
those things to support myself and then
I will be better off right I'm Gonna
Save time I'm Gonna Save money I'm Gonna
Save all of these things I'm Gonna Save
stress by being able to stay focused on
my thing right um staying in your own
lane so with that you guys are here what
do you think we talk a little bit about
this flash sale Carri is a time can we
do it I don't even know what time it is
I just this was all one sentence to me
you know they're waiting let's go let's
just do it so I don't know if you knew
but we have this really cool thing okay
it's called The Future Shop and inside
of it has courses and toolkits and
resources some really cool merch um
there are just there's so many things
but the thing about it is it's not just
one person it's people who are experts
in their individual areas coming in and
teaching you the skills that you need to
succeed in your area right your area of
expertise and Bridge those gaps for you
so if we're looking at business and
you're like you know what I've never
touched my legal I just hope I don't get
sued that's that's not how we do
business okay let's let's not do that so
for you you could be looking and going
oh the legal kit is probably going to be
my jam right like I definitely need that
or let's say you're sending out
proposals to people and you keep getting
no and you're like why right like what
is going on then we have perfect
proposal right if you know that your
systems behind the scenes are not all
that great and you tend to do a lot of
like but I'm a creative I don't know
systemes cool Ben will just help you and
you'll get opsis okay so that that's
going to help you set up those systems
that you need for yourself um if we're
talking about money I'm not going to go
on this tangent but I feel so strongly
about creatives making the money they
deserve and having Financial Freedom for
themselves but you have to face your
money to be able to do that right like
you have to learn how to navigate money
in order to earn more of it so there's
resources for that right like whatever
is that you need for yourself I know
positioning and Legion is a hot one um
for people like we have those tools
available for you so you can look at
your list and go oh I do need these
things right like oh my messaging is not
so great like let me be honest I'm going
to put my stuff out there but the
messaging isn't really strong I should
probably be working on my brand
messaging like you can get the different
tools that you need for yourself or the
different assets um for yourself and
this isn't everything in the shop under
business I just could fit so much in a
screenshot let's be honest so then the
next piece is your creative skill sets
so this is helping you to improve your
craft right these are the things that
going to allow you to go oh okay this
makes me stronger in this area which
means you can charge more you can serve
better you have more clients coming back
because you just do great work right um
I can tell you from personal experience
finding really good creative work can be
a dig right like you're looking all over
online you're like I'm trying to find
you know like this person that does this
specific skill set and all of that which
kind of comes back to the importance of
messaging but if we're looking at the
skill set once I see someone has those
skills I'm like hi you're my
photographer forever we are now best
friends thank you right like that's it
and that's the power of having those
skill sets for yourself so if we're
looking here color for creatives like
anyone can use color not everyone
understands color so if you know that's
a weakness of yours or you're putting
things out there and you're kind of
like like there's something weird about
it but I don't know what it is maybe
it's color right like maybe that is a
weakness of yours but that's okay you
can improve it right like you can get
better with it same thing with grids and
layouts that's another one where I can
tell right away like if I see certain
layouts I'm like something's wrong and
it's really the foundation of grids and
layouts at play it's like oh yeah
because this needed to be here and you
know like all of those type of things um
if we're going to rock your portfolio
like that is one that I know people
loved um within this past um live stream
that they came and grabbed why because
your portfolio matters and it shouldn't
just be a bunch of stuff like all shut
Ed in together it needs to be very
strategic and intentional right um so
making sure that you have that we just
finished um launching brand uh Identity
Design with made by James so of course
that's within our creative uh skill sets
as well we have Carousel design which is
amazing especially if you see Chris's
content and you're just like you were
like me and you kind of came in you're
like what is this sorcery right like
H how is this happening like like I get
what he's doing but like I also I need
to know how I need to know what's going
on like cool there's a course on that
right you have all of these things um
that are available to you and actually
accessible which I think is just an a
cool thing that we have here at the
future now like I said all month these
are 25% off we wanted to keep it super
simple simple I told you about us
brainstorming of like what do we want to
do for this sale what do we want to name
it all of that we're like 25% off across
the board everyone will be happy who
doesn't love saving 25% I love a good
sale but you're on this live stream
which tells me that maybe you want to
save a little bit more and I like
sharing it so if you purchase from the
shop within the next 15 minutes and
we're going to hang here we're going to
answer questions we're going to do all
the things I promise I won't dance too
much um and you use
marketing at checkout you're going to
get 50% off so every price you see
already has it sale all that go put
marketing get yourself 50 so instead of
25 you get 50 and I mean why wanted you
do that right so if you know that you
know I could learn some typography my
color could be a little better maybe you
want to illustrate a little bit more you
want to build some of those skills go
ahead go get yourself some 50% off I
love a deal um this is where I try not
to get too excited because I really love
a good deal um and then if you want your
business skill sets cool this would be
the time where are you at now where are
you going you have your plan or at least
it's in your head if you've been hanging
with us um what are the the pieces of
the puzzle that you can go ahead and
grab so you have them and you have
lifetime access right so it doesn't mean
you have to get them now and immediately
do it over your holiday no this is now
into your 2024 plan all right so Carrie
how we doing this timer do we have a
timer on I'm gonna do it on my yeah I I
got it going we have 15 minutes
everybody go we crashed the internet
last time so all
right so guys the look book yeah the
lookbook is is really good um if you
want to if you're a graphic designer and
you're not quite sure what courses might
work um for your specific field um our
educational director Stephanie did a
fabulous job um just outlining the
courses that we have um that would work
um and help you out there yes Spencer
grabbed color for creatives and
illustration for designers Spencer I
want those two I have color for
creatives and I
I love it I love it I didn't go to
design school so um it really Greg is
amazing and all the the color palettes
that he has in there too like it's
awesome
yep yes and that's what I think um
Charles email uh supportthe
future.com and we'll be good I'm going
to write down your name just so we know
because it sounds like it may not have
worked or you know something happened
there we definitely get you uh handled
for
that the code does not apply for
accelerator program but you can use um
the code thank you all one word and
you'll get $50 off the first
month yes um and this is uh is there one
on how to make pitch decks such as the
one you guys did for the
lookbook do you know because I know we
have a pitch one but I'm not
sure so in the I just want to make sure
Stephanie's in the chat and she's
helping with those that thanks
Stephanie
awesome yes code does not apply to
memberships correct so the way the
membership works so for the accelerator
which I'll go over kind of the the
difference between both so you know um
the accelerator is perfect when you're
like look I have the skills I want more
clients more consistent I want to build
the business right like what is the
support that allows me to be able to do
that then you're going to go into the
accelerator with Ben Burns and Stephanie
Owens who are co-creators of that and
they go through every single step of the
process um as far as getting your work
together building case studies reaching
out to clients all of that and that is a
membership model so that's a little bit
different um but we do have it included
in the salale at $50 off your first
month so you can go in there you can
experience it you can get on a coaching
call which I believe would be this
Friday correct Carrie yep that's right
yep so you can get in there get your
questions
answered see oh good got deser bundle
yay yay
yay we need a like some sort of music to
not cannot handle this I can't wait this
long without what are you doing uh oh I
I'm not gonna put on Britney thank you
I'm like I'm holding on to my chair
going please unless ask for it
unless no I don't think we're allowed to
on YouTube or else I would have already
did
it sorry guys sorry typical
Millennial let's
see
all right I wish I could get that bundle
sell me on let's see I don't think my
code went through all right Stacy we can
double check I'm going to jot down real
quick um you should have a receipt that
comes through right away but I'm GNA
just to like confirm but I'm going to
write down your name and if it doesn't
um reach out to support atth
future.com and we'll let them know
because definitely if there's an issue
with live we want to make sure we get
that all set um just C brand Identity
Design made by James awesome uh Ben and
Steph are absolutely amazing coaches
been an accelerator for sixish months
and my Roa R Roi is absolutely
incredible cannot recommend enough the
community is amazing 500 plus already
Yes like the amount of
testimonials out of accelerator
I love it I love it so much I just one I
love seeing people win but when
creatives are winning like that I'm like
special place special place in the heart
it is so incredible to see and it's a
super engaged
Community Gott the brand Identity Design
um if you're having issues with stripe
if you could email support at the
future.com I've written your name down
um so we'll be on the lookout for for
your
email all
right how are we on time
Carrie we still have 10 minutes we still
have 10 minutes five minutes okay I know
five minutes that's pass we're doing
good five minutes down 10 minutes to go
and will I'm so sorry that your bank
locked down your
card last week because he purchased too
many
courses well let's do it again will
let's do it
again um Antonio trying to buy two
courses ux and color for creatives they
have to be separate purchases correct
Carrie that's correct so you'll go and
check out the for ux and then come back
and um purchase color for
creatives and on the page there will be
an enroll
now um
button yes uh just got opsis awesome you
can geek out on notion with us
now I hate this is is been here because
now I have to admit this publicly so
like I loved I loved a platform and I
won't say the name I guess and then like
we use
notion so went in opsis did the thing
started moving things over to notion and
I'm like
I
mean it is pretty nice I I converted
like couple months ago and the more I
learn I'll get it to him I'll give it to
him he had a twist my arm though so I
don't really like being wrong that much
but like I guess guess I'll give credit
where credits do so you guys if you are
interest eight more minutes y'all
eight awesome eight minutes yeah so
opsis definitely like if you're looking
to learn notion and get all that
streamlined and all of that
goodness that's a that's a good
product um let's see I'm in the
accelerator where can I find the legal
kit and opsis um I probably have step oh
yeah okay Stephanie already answered
that perfect uh just got here welcome uh
what course is this for all of them
like literally all of them okay so if
there's I start grab my pen I'm gonna
wind up throwing it um not do
that y' I wish I was on camera let's we
had hats y'all this would been it would
have been so much fun we had hats you
know what should I show them the Hat do
it anyway come on like just pretend my
icon has this addon so here's a great
lesson and like sometimes things don't
work and you have to just like roll with
it because that's life and that's
business so we were going to come on
here and talk about like the different
hats that we wear as business owners
right because like there's a lot of them
um and we were going to say you can put
on your marketing hat and we were going
to have marketing hats very cool ones
okay I'm really okay so we both had
these but car's camera has decided it
doesn't like the hat and it doesn't want
to play Do It come
on got do the ears do the ears come on
this is not the coolest like look at me
I'm a unique unicorn ever like kind of
hat but it didn't happen you know um and
you know it goes to say too of like
being who you truly are on the internet
because I walked by my husband's office
when this came in and I popped my head
in and I went like this with the ears
and he turned to the cat and he goes
yeah that doesn't surprise
me okay okay just another day just
another day being me are you got are you
guys still having trouble with the
checkout did you break the did you break
it oh did we we can if it's having some
issue I can extend the time for a minute
or two um to let people get we like Tim
Kardashian right
now
I think that's where it started oh I'm
glad you just got you your business not
a freelancer that's a great
lecture
awesome share what else you guys are
purchasing I want to see yes I know this
is probably killing you Carrie because
she likes to see from the behind the
scen scene she can't see that way she
has like I
DOD such a nerd I'm I have to wait till
this is over pocket of dough cool that's
a good
look got the full designer
bundle thanks Charles I love it it is a
lot of information Charles for
sure oh Ben is here I got
caught I got caught with my notion
love uh back up and running we got a kit
okay
see yeah the coupon is working again
yall if you want to look it's like it's
back up the site
[Music]
so use the word
marketing I got really excited because
there was a song I knew but it was
because it was an ad on
YouTube oh
no that real
quick let's see color for creatives in
the brand Identity Design
courses awesome how we on time Carrie we
have about three more minutes but I'm
gonna give everybody just a few more we
since kind of had some tech issues um
let everybody get what they were wanting
to get
there oh please uh course on Workshop
facilitation with Ryan all right noted
CA after this month we start planning
for the new year so all kinds of things
can come out Justin yay complete c um
case study is that's a good one too
yes see yay Rocky portfolio that's our
one of our newest courses with
Stephanie oh let me tell
you when I saw that course and I saw the
price and I said this is Stephanie when
we were at Adobe Max too in person and I
was
like I can't believe it's priced at that
like for everything that's in it and I
just and stuff like that I was like I
hope people
realize I sounded so creepy but I meant
it that voice just kind of like creep me
out there what's going
on but it's like
just I would go on a whole tangent here
but like to be able to
have the right pieces in your
portfolio and then to be able to present
and create the right proposals for your
client like between those two products
alone like the amount of money you can
make far beyond the actual cost of them
right because both of them are less than
100 bucks so it's like what you could
actually make it just just I get really
excited about stuff like that like so
the perfect proposal is something that I
got I started with the future a a long
time ago as a pro member long long long
time ago and um I remember when that
perfect proposal came I just chunked and
trashed mine and the clients were blown
away by this is a
presentation of it you know it it the
information was good too like I had all
my information was it was similar you
know but just the layout the way that we
you take them through the story of the
of the work it's it's just it's great um
that one and then um the legal kit saved
my butt s several times um a lot of
times actually so um on how just to talk
with talk with your clients too so it's
a
it's a good one I started with core
though and core core is still classic
you know
so and I think that's legal is one of
those
things you don't need it till it's too
late type of thing and you're
like I should have right like it's all
fun and games till the client does
something and then you go to post in
like a community or a group or something
and they're like well what does your
contract say you're like oh that dread
question was your contct
well it says nothing because I didn't
send it option b what is it and they're
like sorry right like hope you don't get
sued like those are those things like
but you just don't know like how are you
supposed to know those things until
somebody tells you and or you
unfortunately learn the hard way right
and then you go back and fix it and when
you know better you do better so um
that's why I like have it separated like
that in the shop of like hey these are
the business things these are the
creative skill sets so you can pick and
choose what's needed for where you're at
right now yeah we have a question is
there a problem if I can't start with a
course right now absolutely not these
are you have it for as long as they're
up and forever and you can start at your
own pace stop and start um they work
with your time
frame yes um me see just purchase we're
gonna do two more minutes um two more
minutes uh we we've already hit the 15
but I'm giving a couple minutes for our
Tech issues that we had there okay so we
got two minutes two minutes I'm shutting
it down and then please don't say I'm
sorry I missed it and like please open
it again because we can't we literally
cannot but if you're having trouble
please email support atthe future.com um
and we'll you know we'll get you
straight ux
fundamentals yay oh hand lettering
thinking about
accelerator it do it and it's $50 off
the first month uh use the coupon code
thank you um I don't think you'll regret
it yeah and the thing I like about
memberships is it is month to month
right so it's like personally I feel
like there's risk sometimes for bigger
things right to be able to go oh okay I
understand this will take a while to go
through um but if for some reason it's
not for you oh I got that like I saved
coming in for the first month to be able
to find out um I also have a personality
that doesn't like wondering what if so
I'll always like I'd rather do the thing
and get the answer without wondering
what if um so that's just my own kind of
personal decision- making if it's
something that can truly help blogging
for Creative entrepreneurs somebody's
going into a
Blog
awesome uh oh great Justin I'm glad
you're already seeing value and you just
purchased
Friday love it uh Charles Rock your
portfolio you'll get a month of
accelerator no was that a attempt thing
so inside of rock your
portfolio I want to say it's the last
lesson if I'm remembering correctly
there is a code that you can apply um
for a dollar your first month in
accelerator and that's at the end of
rock your portfolio though so it's like
make sure you go through that first um
so you have you know all of those pieces
you do not need rock your portfolio
before going in an accelerator but
because they are aligned and that is a
course within um accelerator that's an
option for you I got too many courses
not possible I can't have too many
courses well now you know what you're
doing next year so when you see all the
different things on your feed you can go
no I'm good like I already know just
promise me y'all that you'll do the
course and you'll implement this is not
an excuse for you not to do your
marketing plan learn the things and take
action on
them yes as much as I would love for
things to happen through just pure
osmosis osmosis yeah it would be great
we also have to show up and do the thing
right yeah all right guys I am a couple
more seconds and I'm shutting this puppy
down I know I can't bre it I know it's
great oh you guys are awesome thank you
for being here today for hanging out
with us for having fun with our
marketing letting us share with you and
also snagging yourself a deal along the
way some 50% off um I saw people got a
couple of uh different things which is
just super exciting to be able to see
because there are some great great
products from some pretty amazing
people let's
see and also y'all if today's not the
day and you want to shop some more later
25% off is happening until the end of
the month so that that is not going away
yes Brian said four new courses for
total of 18 owned courses that is
amazing Brian that's awesome it's an
expensive
week Imagine I read all you save though
I mean it could have been a lot more
expensive that is awesome um let's see
thanks for the time and expertise
absolutely future is the best thing that
I've ever stumbled upon thank you for
all that you
do let's see I wish I didn't have a day
job oh let me tell
you it teaches you time management I
think there's so many Pros to that as
well um maybe because I was someone who
went full-time then on my own then back
to full-time but when I went on my own
it was almost like well now I have all
this
time and I had to learn to be effective
with it CU I didn't know right and I was
like oh there was actually a gift with
still working full-time cuz I was way
more efficient
with business because I had to be right
so y take that for what you will but
just maybe a little bit of a a reframe
that could be helpful for you because I
wish I knew that before and I was like
oh look at
that all right y'all I am pushing the
button we're going to be closing this
flash
sale thank you everybody yes
bye oh we're we're just knocking off
here would you like see you bye yeah
yeah we're done
bye well yes thank you to everybody
for joining us um I think Chris is
having a um a LinkedIn audio um on
Thursday about brand strategy um I hope
you guys tune in for that it should be a
good
one we will see you there all right
bye